do you guys think that sex work is
immoral
no he comments on that actually go ahead
so I I don't fans but it wasn't like
boobs it was lingerie yeah boobs
whatever I done it and when I finished
it I felt very degraded I felt very like
why did I actually do that now I know
there's girls out there who do that they
don't feel that way that is perfectly
fine you do you you feel the way you
feel but me personally like like in the
future how like when I have kids and all
in the future and if my kids found out
about that they'll probably get bullied
in school there are people like oh your
mom doing this your mom doing that and
your man as well he's not going to if
you don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not a there's not a high
respect for yourself why expect that
from others then you know what I mean
and it's like if you're doing that sex
work it's so different for you how much
money did you make into so I basically
done it like consecutively for like a
week like literally I posted the first
week in total first week I made about
two thousand that was from people being
nosy and from people
and first week in one week
if you seen the stuff that people would
ask you and even outside even to this
day I don't do it anymore but people
still being like me oh well you used to
have only fans like what was that like
you you must be real freak no why are
you doing for what they talking about
it's because I wasn't posting this whole
vagina I wasn't doing the whole thing
you know what I mean so you won
you ain't so no none and you know I
showed the titties I showed the titties
but I didn't I didn't show nothing else
you know what I mean and it was kind of
to a point where it's like
I thought I could do that when I got
onto it do you think she won money but
she didn't win respect
do you think that you should be judged
for doing sex work
to an extent it don't I don't care what
anybody says in my opinion it does
speak a lot about yourself it does it
100 even for me like what I've done it
people knew the type of girl I was like
I'm very out there I'm open I don't care
I'll speak what I speak and say what I
say and do what I do but when I done it
I just didn't expect to be like wolf
whatever what did you expect
were you thinking before you did it
before I did it I was like get me get
the bag get some money just get some
money see well was there someone that
influenced you to do it oh yeah I see
all these girls doing and getting the
money
on Instagram Tick Tock some girls I know
and I'm like girl get it if that's what
you want to do that is perfectly fine
like do you me personally I couldn't do
it like that do you understand if a guy
would disqualify you in the future for
that that was the first thing I said I
can understand how a man would look at
me and why why do you think that you
accept that where other girls will call
the man misogynistic feelings they're
not using their logic they're like how
dare you speak about me like that and
it's like you're taking it so personal I
was like you obviously must feel a
specific way about yourself if that's
how you're speaking about man a man
being misogynistic because he won't take
you up for that that that's about your
own respect levels and that's that's
just your own opinion like do you do you
guys think that sex work is immoral
um
speaking to your mic just here I forgot
to an extent yes
um a lot of points that you mentioned
I'd agree with I feel like it comes off
very
desperate and
I just don't generally feel like
um doing them sort of things
don't make you seem like a very good
person
in the way of so it's not your fault
like I'm not blaming you for it how is
it not your fault
whose fault is it I think I think
genuinely like I feel like obviously I'm
not gonna put the blame on everyone else
I thought I believe everyone should take
accountability for their actions and
whatnot but I feel like upbringing
and the like Financial State you're in
can influence you a lot with them sort
of things but you can look at someone
that's born in the same upbringing and
they don't make those decisions yeah 100
[Music]
um
I feel like they
even just being born in this Century
you're richer than most people were in
all of human history that's true I agree
with that I just feel like because again
going on back onto the part of the
society that we're in now obviously back
in the day it was prostitution that was
looked down upon more now only fans is
being favored especially by like men and
whatnot like men that start only fans
um they get favored they're like all
right he's he's doing his thing like his
[__] different [__] every night
type Vibe it's like it gets favored and
it's normalized to the point where you
think men make more money on only fans
than women
um I don't know the statistics so I
won't speak on that but um obviously I
know I I personally know men that I run
only fans and they do make money like
what's make money as in like they make
how much a substantial amount of
probably like 30k a month so like it is
a thing obviously it's not as normal as
women doing it but it is a thing it's
crazy how men were the ones that kind of
that kind of run the porn society and
it's the women that are falling into it
oh sorry corn Society my apologies have
they run the corn societies but
obviously women being consumers as it is
we're going to be the ones to jump into
it more you know what I mean compared to
men yeah okay so what do you think
um is sex work immoral yes I absolutely
think so for any sex it doesn't even
matter male or female we weren't made to
do that right like um even just the fact
that we have to wear clothes and layers
is to protect right so even before you
put on your regular clothes you have on
undergarments right and so that in and
of itself just shows the default nature
of how that's supposed to be more sacred
it's supposed to be more private more
secure right we even refer to it as
private parts private areas so
absolutely it's a moral to just be
flaunting that and giving it to anyone
period what about you
um so for myself I would say it would be
immoral for me but I I don't know like I
think
is morality different is morality
different for different people like if I
steal and you steal it's different
General nigh but I think some people
will kind of rationalize what they're
doing and then say that they have their
reasons for it and then I'm not I don't
know their lives so I don't know what
their reasons would be but if I still
because I'm hungry does that does that
make it different it's not okay but
people are going to do what they're
gonna do so if they do it nobody I'm
asking if you think it's moral no I've
not for me I wouldn't no but for
everyone do you think it's moral no no
okay okay thank you oh go ahead hell no
and I and I think like now
um you know I also think as I get older
like I had a daughter what would my
answer be right like I think it's you
know just think about that but also too
like I think the word the terminology
sex work is it's it's a really like
large term there's a lot of things that
could be encompassed within that but I
also think uh sex work you know could be
you know a lot of these Hollywood stars
that you know show up half naked to the
red carpet right like I was looking at
the Oscars and Sierra just showed up to
the Oscars uh like literally half naked
and she has two or three kids and is
married to a a a multi multi-millionaire
Russell Wilson that to me is a component
of sex work as well because she's taking
degrees of her sexuality putting it
somewhere and and going to get brand
deals because of it right like and
everything that comes from it right so
like I even think when we talk about sex
worker the definition has to be expanded
for modern times today because although
she's not doing that and getting direct
money or maybe that she is from the
outfit that she's wearing she could be
right but then also what comes of that
right and if there's an exchange of
money then that's sex work as well
my my thought was on the different
everybody else
um I don't really see nothing wrong with
it
because like
since we're been going on since the
beginning of time it's never gonna stop
have you ever had a problem no I don't I
don't I don't buy I don't do that but
I'm just saying it's gonna happen like
women gonna get money they're gonna use
what they got to get money man gonna do
the same thing see I'm like torn on it
because on one hand
I sometimes agree with you like I
sometimes think it's needed in a society
because
what are the one in three men gonna do
and if you if you think sex is a need
which it sort of is for men
but then it just makes my stomach turn
to say that too
[Music]
let me ask you let me ask you something
who you think have sex move
a regular girl
or somebody who do only fans like who
got one person one person who they sleep
with an only fan they do only thing who
you think I would agree who you think
having sex mode or a stripper for some
for just a regular girl
no I think it's the I think girls that
do promiscuous Behavior are like tend to
make more promiscuous like choices like
I think if someone does that they're
probably more likely to sleep around
that's my opinion I know some people
will say no but yeah
I would really be able to do okay I'm
with you I don't know why I'm always
with you but I'm with you
[Music]
um
we've been close with a stripper or kind
of see what they what they do like they
schedule how they work
damn really yeah they they going to the
club doing anything they come home count
up their money get up in the morning go
to the bank deposit them once they ain't
really out here just messing around like
that but it might be another girl who
going to the strip club
just throwing ones on them but they
[__] that night yeah I want girls in
the strip club are desensitized to it
right so that they're when you are
tripping for a man and doing that you
have to sell a fantasy to him right you
have to get into this Persona and give
him the dream for the night so he will
give you the money right and so once you
come off of that in your home and you're
with your family or whatever you usually
they have kids that they're taking care
of and they're doing stuff for they're
exhausted they're tired because I just
had to go and pretend to be someone that
I wasn't and I don't even want I'm I'm
disgusted by men to a certain degree
right because I know how creepy they are
they come here and they're their most
vulnerable and nasty and all the stuff
that everyone else is going to look at
you crazy for I have to take it because
you're paying me to take it so I think
they're desensitized to it honestly I
can see your point and then on the other
end
um it's a girl I'm not gonna say her
name but she's super big on only fans
like she she getting like 200 000 a
month on the fan she only she only sleep
with one dude on only fan yeah there's
girls like that as well think about it
she getting money you can't you can't
you don't get more money than her and
she already got a dude who who pleases
her essentially so she's not you're not
gonna even go be able to go mess with
yeah but but the question is based on
morality morality is grounded in
principles so then but what would you be
okay but what is morality what are the
things that we do on every on every day
for the for money but let's say that you
had a daughter as a father you pass on
virtues you you pass on values you pass
on principles you pass on morality
if your daughter is doing that is that
something yeah I'm not gonna agree with
my daughter doing it so then the answer
to the question for you is no I'm not
I'm not going I wouldn't agree with my
my daughter or my senior doing a lot of
[__] I do but yeah
okay
baby lead them in the right way and Hope
and hope they grow up and do the things
that you'll be pleased with yeah
I think there's a place for them I think
it's been there for a long time I think
that if you're going to be a sex worker
you should be single you shouldn't
expect no man and there should be a [__]
Island
Island and you know like was it called
Hit the box was it called it that box
thing
so like can regular people go to the
island like you know I think that's
something
we should do a reality show for me I
think it becomes tomorrow when they
they're looking for they've got children
they've got Partners or they expect to
get a man through it and I think that if
you're going to be a sex worker that's
where you're going to be I I I want to
say this will be nothing else and expect
to be a wife you shouldn't be a mom I
think if you're a mother and you're
you're a sex worker you're the only fans
I think if you're a partner and you're
the only fan or anything like that I
think of your wife
no but other than that if you're single
you want to go and do it and you're
harming no one go to slow Island
not everyone as women know I do think
now I will say this and it ain't my
place to say this either but I do think
it's a time limit on it yeah
at a certain point so you old is here
you need to get your at the streets but
nobody's gonna want you after that
that's what I'm saying stay on the
island because once you've started
there's women out there it depends it
depends how bad that she is if you see
that there's an article about like an 80
year old woman on Tinder guys were still
yeah
she'll be like the five dollar special a
scent will always forgive if she bad
enough yeah um I'm curious what do you
guys think is sex work moral immoral um
uh I don't know I I personally think
like I have a lot of friends and a lot
of people so maybe I'm a bit
desensitized to it but I think corn has
been happening for ages I think as
consent in adults you know well corn has
it yeah it's been okay how before
even before like think about it we had
sex with the statues even of naked women
like women have always been kind of
admired for their bodies yes the statues
are the same thing as like not really
but I mean as in nicer admiring women
for their bodies and like I don't know I
just we don't think there's a difference
between like a sexual picture and like a
beer because some of the orders
pictures of the side
um wouldn't it be the same difference
though
whose phone's ringing
um some but some of the older pictures
it's it's because time to move forward
though so I can imagine even sex back
then wasn't how we have sex now you know
we've become more and more uh modern
freaky disgusting
disgusting you know people what people I
think watch corn really early and normal
sex becomes boring and you want to spice
things up and you do more and more
things that maybe didn't happen back in
the day not say that that's right or
wrong it's for everything yeah well yeah
yeah
so to answer the question moral or
immoral I don't think it's immoral no I
just I think it's moral
so then you think it's immoral I I don't
know each to their own I think it's each
to their own I think if moral or immoral
we gotta
I think if you're single and like you
said Andy said it was moral yeah I think
it is moral as long as it suits your
lifestyle and like she said I think as
long as you don't expect to for everyone
just to accept it and understand I think
it's moral I said Don't expect a man
don't expect anyone to marry you I think
women too actually make sure you're
talking in here sorry you shouldn't have
any children don't expect a man once you
decide on the sex work that's you too
you die get sex work insurance no I'm
not saying that I think I'm saying
that's how it should be because if
somebody knows that this is how you
start you're not you're gonna you're not
gonna get anybody that should be able to
put women off but there's women again
out there say I can go and be only
friends and I can still get a husband I
can be gonna be only fans I'm not going
to have my children I can be only fans
no after you know that that is it you're
gonna have to take dick for the rest of
your life
you get the scraps women that go out and
don't do only you don't get high value
I'm talking about like just normal
people that when they don't have their
children they go out and they sleep with
loads of people and they don't do only
fans but they still get married
because we've got not weave because
there's a platform that you're like
showcased on it's highlighted but
there's a lot of women in privacy that
do a lot worse than women
do you know what it says if you go on
only fans that you have no shame
even
you think kids don't mind I mean kids
don't obviously kids don't have like the
same view I mean like mums and dads like
some people just you know and that's but
it's still saying I'm putting my my
money before bringing shame to the
family name
depending on what your family view is on
it right but I'm saying what are the
kids get no say in this so it still it
still goes back to I always talk about
this the me me culture where it's me
before the children yeah oh okay well
hopefully the kids will turn out fine
but you know I need this money so I'm
gonna do this now there's a lot of porn
stars with children that are okay as
well foreign
so the way that you talk it's kind of
like in this this um this my truth you
know it just is what it is everyone can
make decisions but at the same time as I
hear it it sounds like people can make
decisions without repercussions or
Consequences and I think that's on a
slippery slope because when we do that
it starts to get away from
accountability and the thing is is like
when you look at generally what men
typically want out of women men
typically do not want women that have
been conquered sufficiently and
especially have done it for money and
especially have put their risk enters up
on the internet but there's also a
massive miscon misconception that
that um the gentleman said there's a lot
of women that only said boyfriend on
so that
the Inception that if you do only found
your easy words it's most of the time
it's actually very opposite to get in
contact with this woman normally you
have to pay up front like you're not con
she's not responding she gets so many
DMS a day she's not going to respond to
you and it's a moral in the way of like
money money money comes first but I'm
saying there's a misconception that just
because a girl does only fans that she's
maybe easy or easy easy access
but that's not what I'm saying it's it's
sex Work men of value if you can if you
want to in the entertainment besides
let's say like a Kanye West what people
in entertainment have women that have
done only fans publicly there's a lot of
people that do Playboy and like maybe
not as um as graphic but there's still
there's still many real women with
children
my memory is terrible it should be easy
if it happens a lot there's loads five
if you would have asked me to before I
could have probably researched it but no
not off the top of my head no do you
guys but I'm saying if this was common
if this was common we should be able to
to name five or at least one two three
off the top of your head I think far too
often when we have these conversations
if women if women's goal is to be with
men then you have to consider what men
want and irrespective of the brand
if she had been involved with that it's
going to deselect a lot of women and
here's the thing there's a lot of women
are sitting in situationships that think
they're in good standing with the man
but the man just don't say ish yeah but
they continue they continue in that
situationship and just don't don't tell
her the truth while it's still
extracting and then as soon as things
while still extracting their insides so
they're getting what they want and that
they already know there's going to be an
expiration date at the end of it yeah so
the thing is is what is your goal and
how are you working towards your goal
what are the actions that you're putting
in the place and I think if we if it's
on a slippery slope where you're not
understanding what men want and if the
result is a man that you have to make
some changes within the way that you
move within that well I think it's
obviously it started the only fans
she's not talking about getting married
that's the last thing on my mind exactly
that's not what you're trying to do
until time Runs Out fantastic yeah and
then she has to think about something
have you ever thought about it or
considered it or done it only fan um or
stripping no because you just seem
really like part of you like you're in
the circle you know I have a lot of I
have a lot of close friends that do it
and I can understand
um and even being a photographer that
does laundry and I I promote body
positivity so I post myself in laundry
and why my content I'm plus size I try
to like I mean so it's not it's not
exactly that but like it's kind of
within a tiny bit of a window with it
you go further
um do you think you're gonna start there
now and you're gonna get so body
positivity you're gonna get so positive
about your body you're gonna think you
know what my friends are doing it I can
go and be positive only fans that get
paid for it it's like a Domino's if I
did I would understand the repercussions
do I mean okay it just sounds like
you're you're already invested in that
whole yeah I just think I don't know I
just think some like there's a bit of an
unfair Vision on it sometimes but I
understand why do you know what I mean
but it's like when you're arguing it's
kind of like do I want a thief in my
house no right yeah does it matter if
you know maybe maybe that maybe that
Thief stole five dollars worth of stuff
and that Thief stole 50 but they're
still both thieves and that's what I'm
saying with the guys the way the guys
think about promiscuity okay maybe maybe
the regular girl's worst that's not in
sex work but then guys don't want either
hmm can I just say that if you're
speaking about regular girls to do it
they're not actually putting out there
so you wouldn't know what they're doing
anyway and also saying that girls that
are in sex work might not do it as
regular as a regular girl but maybe they
haven't actually been given the
opportunity if they're trying to make
money off it so who like sex workers if
you're saying that they do it
um less than a regular girl oh
to your point you said like sometimes
regular girls do it more than a sex
worker but maybe the sex workers are not
meeting anything we're not actually
willing to yeah
the opportunity if you if you move
around we know it goes from grouped
after group for sure boys know boys boys
know that like if you think that you're
private and you've had sex with say 20
boys and they don't know each other
they know men no 100 yeah we call that
the whole facts
even but it's like all right let's let's
see me you first started talking they
just haven't been given the opportunity
to
they're wanting money from it so it's
like if they got 20 like guys a week
then I'll give you this would they do it
and then be worse the regular girl
because now they're actually getting
paid for it whereas a lot of guys will
be as soon as they find out a girl wants
money for it they're not going to do it
because why would I give you money when
I can get it for free and a lot of men
argue sorry that oh I wouldn't subscribe
to an only fans because I have girls
that send it to me for free so the
actual nudes and the spreading and all
that stuff isn't the issue it is the
money part
lingo
while I'm in Atlanta
we feel like a girl been around and we
know she's been around we say she burnt
out you know what I'm saying now if you
own only fans or if you're not on the
fans you can still be burnt out is
wait we can tell we could tell about how
you how we how you move you know what
I'm saying so let's say me and you first
started dealing with each other well I
don't know you we just talking with
divide cool whatever
I'm gonna take you to the club let's go
to the club let's go to a spot where
everybody be at
when we walk in this spot I can I can
tell about how you move around in this
spot and who let me in here know you and
I can just I can look at how you acting
until how you move and whether you burnt
out or not so it ain't got nothing to do
with only fans ain't got nothing to do
with none of that is about how you
really moving out here and man gonna
know we're gonna know are y'all not good
enough to hide that [__] I don't know
like a lot of girls that go to the club
you they might not actually do it
whereas you will meet a lot of like home
bodies for example that they're always
at home but a man's always with them
like and it don't have to be the same
man it could just be different man you
wouldn't know because if someone feels
ashamed about it or anything they're not
going to tell you they'll just lie so
you will never know really what goes on
in someone's life unless you've got
proof I always hear from guys that like
women always tell on themselves that a
girl can fool you but only for so long
do you guys think that's true yeah for
sure you're gonna know like maybe not at
first like I feel like it's like maybe
not at first but if you do enough
someone's gonna talk and so you might
you might see another quiet girl at the
party or whatever but then you know you
get to know her a little better you see
who's around her and someone's you know
a seated as you living in now if you're
going to a fresh City and don't nobody
know you Ronnie
we played football in London we we
graduated from London we went to college
we went to different colleges around
here
when I get to bringing you around as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible